foreign
[Music]
you're right to Copenhagen yesterday
yeah yeah this is not your first time in
Copenhagen right I've been here many
times yeah so anything you do when
you're in Copenhagen like something you
need to do when you're here oh that's
the hardest question I thought that
wasn't in the script
walk around walk around that yeah yeah I
don't have a bicycle no a year but but
uh really enjoy walking around and it
buildings in particular like uh you have
so many pretty buildings around and and
the visit is just really nice but you
didn't go swimming did you no no next
time you'll go swimming yeah sure uh
welcome everybody I need to know how
many trained economies do we have in the
audience
okay it's nothing to be embarrassed
about okay but I think we didn't ask
them where they were trained
they called them an economist anyway
okay
let's give him a hand
the
hi okay
[Applause]
wow and the reason I ask about the
numbers of economists in the audience
because like you
like you said yes to teach us a class of
Economics like that you will educate Us
in economics in five minutes
you will learn us like the three most
important Concepts
okay well that was all when he asked me
to try to summarize uh all of what
people do for years and years and five
minutes that's a real challenge so I
suppose the first thing is uh resources
are scarce
uh and uh the essential questions are
uh what gets produced how it gets
produced for whom it gets produced but a
fourth question that is often not
focused upon is who decides the answers
to these questions and that's really
almost on the verge of politics but it's
really a key issue so the second uh
basic idea is
um
markets are an important mechanism for
answering
those questions for allocating resources
but markets are only one of the
mechanisms
and over the last 50 years we've learned
both the strengths of strengths of
markets but also the limits when and why
they often don't work so right now
I think you're seeing energy markets not
working very well in Europe
and that's just one example
we see lots of in in the U.S we've had
uh exploitation we we have shortages of
baby formula markets didn't work we've
had exploitation the drug companies
caused the opioid crisis
where life expectancy has been going
down in the United States for years now
um so there are these huge problems as
well as strengths and trying to
understand
uh the Richer ecology so so what about
the concepts of Notions of inflation
interest rates Supply demand Philips
curve Keynes Karl Marx Ricardo all this
they teach at the University you don't
need to know all these Concepts in order
to be a common Economist
um well they're they're useful and that
gets you into some of the controversies
I mean obviously if markets work
perfectly there wouldn't be unemployment
but and there are some economists who
actually believe there's no such thing
as unemployment they say that when
people are unemployed they're just
enjoying leisure
and uh you know my response to that is
usually when people are enjoying leisure
they're happy
uh but when people are unemployed they
do things like families break up their
suicide breaks go up they're all
symptoms that they're not happy and so
it's very clear the market often doesn't
work so sum up scarcity the way markets
work that are imperfect and that
politics matters that's right okay so
now you're all trained economists and
and after which you can pick up a
diploma and you can just put it on your
resume inflation the current the current
economic turmoil like everything is up
in there it's just an exciting time to
be an economist I think that's right
yeah but but today like we had the
inflation figures out in Denmark's 8.9
and the US is 8.5 and the European
unions is 9.5 like what is going on
should we be excited or scared
uh well
I think uh
uh both uh
I I think you should be scared because
I'm almost sure that the central banks
the ECB and the Federal Reserve are
going to mess it up
um
and
they're going to mess it up because I
think uh they're going to raise interest
rates too fast too far and cause an
economic downturn
and uh
this is an example you were you know
mentioning a number of names ideology
plays a very big role in economics and
even in quote scientific economics so
people uh if you're a central Banker one
of the things that happens is uh it gets
into your DNA that whenever you see
inflation you raise interest rates
whatever the cause whatever the
consequence that's what if you're a
central Banker that's what you do
but this inflation is not like a normal
inflation or normal inflation they want
normal having but usual inflation is
there's excess demand because the
government's printed too much money or
expenditures are too high uh but there's
excess demand and uh
demanding Supply if there's excess
demand prices go up
but this is caused by supply shortages
and uh perfectly predictable uh
uh if you don't uh in the United States
for instance uh the car companies forgot
to order chips a little mistake so when
the pandemic ended they wanted to start
producing cars people wanted to buy cars
they couldn't produce cars and the
result of that is car prices went way up
and that is was a very big part of our
inflation but that was also was a
shortage of food you know food prices
went up
Energy prices went up particularly with
the Russian invasion of Ukraine
and all of that led to inflation
interesting thing in the United States
where
we don't have some of the we didn't make
the terrible mistake of getting
excessively dependent on Russian gas you
know that was you say something about
Europe yeah you know I wrote in one of
my books I I you know I hate to say I
told you so but I'm but I'm about to say
that
in in one of my books called making
globalization work that I wrote in 2006
I said very explicitly it was very
very foolish for Germany and Europe to
become
so dependent on Russian gas you know
whatever you think of Russia it was not
reliable and what I say now you know the
sun is not reliable but solar renewable
energy is so much more reliable than
being dependent on authoritarian
governments but maybe that's because
we're in Europe we believe in the good
goodness of everyone even in Putin and
we believe in we believe in
interdepotence and world trade and trade
that we should all connect to each other
yeah I mean some of that
is across Atlantic our President Bush
looked as said he looked into the eyes
of Putin and he said this is somebody I
can trust yeah but
when I went to Russia I didn't think
that but the the fundamental problem
was the Reliance on markets and
markets work sometimes as I said before
but not others markets don't reflect
the uh consequences
of uh
CO2 pollution and global climate change
I mean just don't deal with that markets
also don't deal well with risk and that
was to the point I was trying to make
you know
being dependent on Russian gas books
this extraordinary risky
but markets are short-term and they said
oh we can get Russian gas for a little
bit cheaper and we can save a little
money
looking for you say well that's a you
know that's a stupid thing to do because
you're going if
Russia changes and uh
something happens and you don't have
Russian gas you're going to be in a
difficult place I used to work in
politics and whenever you lose an
argument which happens quite often then
you just say let's look to the Future
so how do we solve this problem of
inflation now it's here well so first
what I said is it's a supply side
problem and which means it's a
supply-side problem which means for all
the trade economists that that that the
cost of production are going up uh oil
and energy and food and that leads
prices to go up
but some of that is temporary
like we didn't forget how to make cars
you know we still know how to make cars
as bad as they are but we are learning
how to even make electric cars so uh as
soon as we got chips
the car production would go start and
the price of cars will go down
and that's what's happening if you talk
to uh you know Isaac Jackson to talk to
the CEO of one of the big car companies
he said by the end of the year we're
going to have the car problem solved and
the price will come down the price of
energy went way up it's still high but
the United States has come down so when
inflation in the United States actually
over the last two months has been zero
so we've gotten you know I don't want to
say it's going to stay there but
if you get control of this of of these
factors that are driving the prices
uh
inflation will come down the important
point I want to make though is Raising
interest rates
is not going to cause there to be more
energy more food more cars it's not
going to solve the problem but it will
take heat out of the economy right yeah
if you take enough heat of the economy
and cause a deep enough depression
prices will be moderated but the Cure is
worse than the disease it's not going to
have a very big effect better are some
of the things that actually Europe is
trying to do
which are
supply side effects try to curb the
price of energy the way Europe
uh priced energy linking it with the
cost of gas
led to an enormous disturbance it's not
like the average cost of energy of
electricity has gone up a thousand
percent
it's going up a lot yeah but it's not
anywhere near as much as the price of
electricity is going up in England and
many other countries so as a politician
what do you do I think for a normal
Danish family it will be an additional
cost of almost 1 500 euros one thousand
five hundred dollars a month with the
election price going up what should you
do as a politician in this environment
so let me first talk about the United
States because that's easier and then
and then come to your for the United
States it's actually relatively easy
America is close to energy neutral
so the increase in the price of energy
has been nothing but a redistribution
from ordinary consumers
to the fossil fuel companies
they're the winners
and Americans consumers ordinary
households are the losers and it's just
a redistribution so the answer is pretty
obvious
a windfall profits tax
is what you
ought to impose with the proceeds
distributed
in ways that protect the most vulnerable
it's so obvious windfall property tax
that's a that's a tax on super profit
right on the increase in profits it's
not you know when I I sometimes jokingly
say that you know CEOs and companies say
they need to get a reward for their
efforts
so I jokingly say if Exxon had actually
been behind the war in Ukraine and had
persuaded Putin then you might argue
that Exxon ought to get rewarded
perversely and probably sent to jail but
uh but the fact is he had nothing to do
with it so why is Exxon getting all
these profits why is the CEO going to
get rewarded I'm sure with the bonus
because profits have gone up was it
anything that he did to deserve it
absolutely not
but so the answer is very very simple we
know what the normal profit level is
what they're all the excessive profits
ought to be taxed away and and then
redistributed to those who are who are
suffering and now you have 30 seconds to
answer the Hot Pot Europe well Europe
obviously is in a more difficult
position but there are enormous excess
profits still in in uh many of the
companies that are involved in the
energy market so there are still oil
producers who are making a bundle
uh gas producers are making a bundle one
of the interesting things is that Norway
which is one of the beneficiaries has
made statements about a willingness to
pay those extra taxes to help the rest
so you know when there is a little bit
of social solidarity you actually
get a support for a windfall profits tax
it sounds more difficult in Europe I
think well I mean if there were more
companies like stock like Ecuador which
is the new form of stat oil although oil
companies don't want to label about oil
so they've changed their names like BP
being Beyond petroleum uh rather
rather than the British Petroleum but
the fact is they are making lots of
money and in a way that cannot be
justified in terms of Just Desserts for
their efforts and that and at the same
time parts of our population European
population are suffering enormously in
2002 you wrote this book globalization
and it's discontent it was like it's an
instant classic I think it's fair to say
is this the end of globalization we are
seeing now
I think globalization is really uh being
challenged
um I mean there are certain aspects of
globalization that have really I think
we should call attention to and
celebrate right now brings things uh if
you think about
the pandemic and the production of the
vaccine when I think about how that was
produced with the basic research done by
Hungarian woman working in an American
University
and then brought to Market largely by
some Turkish scientists working in a
German
company
that's an example of globalization that
worked well where it's a globalization
of our ideas where scientists all over
the world pulled their ideas together to
very quickly
uh
generate
a vaccine against uh
covet 19. but then you look at other
aspects of where we are today things are
very uh
ugly I mean the fact that uh
the WTO refused to give a waiver on
intellectual property
for the copenback 19 vaccine even though
governments
Finance more than 90 percent of the cost
uh resulting in you know tens of
thousands of people dying and and
probably hundreds of thousands of
millions getting the disease
unnecessarily unnecessarily and allowing
the disease to pester so it can mutate
and hurt us with mutations that were
more uh uh contagious or more dangerous
that was a real failure of globalization
where the rules that we are constructed
really were exhibit a kind of
selfishness that has undermined Global
solidarity enormously
but right now uh
there are two things going on that are I
think long term
uh going uh three things about that are
going to undermine globalization
um
the first two uh are obvious uh uh the
war Russia's invasion of Ukraine
obviously is has polarized the world
um
the U.S probably
over characterizes it as a war between
democracy and authoritarianism
but that then fits into the second issue
which is the U.S
and this is bipartisan uh
has developed a real
opposition to China
and and uh how this plays out is a
matter of speculation but but clearly
it's going to Europe is being caught in
the middle of that particular idea uh
battle
um
and the third
is exhibited you know in the beginning
of the
uh Russia invasion of Ukraine the
developing countries were very
supportive of uh uh the West in the
resisting uh the attack on Ukraine but
that has waned and that's partly because
of the increase in food and energy
prices but partly out of
a real anger
at how we treated covid-19 vaccines you
know what we thought was a battle just
about intellectual property in Europe in
Geneva
AS Global ramifications because the West
was so selfish
that you know there was that all that
vaccine hoarding that they called
vaccine apartheid
that and they were left to die
uh has I think left a a bitterness that
I feel very strongly in the third world
so so that there has been an increasing
uh split that we should be really
worried about globalization that this
this could be the end of globalization I
wouldn't say the end but it will be a
reshaping the doctrines that about free
flow of ID a free flow of goods capital
across countries
it's always a little bit of of a myth
that idea I think is is really being
questioned let me just give you one
example
um
you may know that United States passed a
some 250 billion dollar
uh Bill to uh try to get a chip industry
inside the United States you know
industrial policy to to try to
strengthen uh the production of Chip so
we wouldn't be so dependent on Taiwan
to me what what was so interesting about
that and I I think it's a good idea that
we
we have that capacity
but
if I waited the WTO rules without any
question
but there was no questioning in the
United States about that no one I mean I
really nowhere in the media nowhere in
when I talked to Secretary of Commerce
or we talked to anybody no one asked the
question well
is this consistent with WTO rules WTO
was viewed almost as uh an institution
of ancient history I think we went to
busy watching the Creations so that's uh
that's probably why people they don't
react but the one who created that
really made attention and there's a lot
of political impact on what's going on
in Ukraine uh they're right now
throughout the Western World in Europe
and in the US there's a huge increase in
defense spending is that a wisely way to
spend our money
well
um you know you wish you didn't have to
spend money on defense
uh and
um I once you know I wrote one book uh
in the midst of the uh war in Iraq
where I was very concerned about uh all
this defense spending and I said we were
spending you know billions and billions
and billions of dollars on weapons that
didn't work against enemies that didn't
exist
and uh
but the fact is that the Russian
invasion
is a message that we still live in a
world where things happen that where we
have to defend ourselves
now I think we have to
think more carefully you know the kind
in general the the war the kinds of Wars
conflicts were likely to fight are going
to be different
and uh
uh more the spending obviously has to be
on cyber security than it was uh before
but for Europe I think the there is an
important lesson uh not so much of the
war in Ukraine
uh but uh having to do with the United
States
I think you have to ask the question
what would have happened if Trump were
the president when Russia invaded
no I mean that's a that's a a scary
question
but it is a hypothetical that is not
that far from reality I mean he claims
he won the election in 2020 but uh but
uh I mean the reality is that
there is a certain
um
riskiness of American politics that you
cannot rely you know that 80 percent of
the Republican party has become a cult
where they are trying to suppress
free elections they are trying to
gerrymander they are trying to prevent
African-Americans Hispanics from voting
um
they're trying to uh you know actually
make sure that people who will uh who
are the register who oversees electoral
process are partisans and will not give
a fair reading so uh as sad as it is for
me I I think the reality is that Europe
has to rely on itself and that means you
do have to spend more on your own
defense I really think it is important
for anybody who believes in democracy
and human rights you're one of the
strongest critic of the European Union
especially the European monetary Union
do you think that that we are able to
take care of ourselves or do we still
need our American big brother to look
after us uh my criticism what I said was
that the Euro was a halfway house and as
a halfway house it was not stable you
either had had to have it it was an
economic Arrangement where the economics
had gotten ahead of the politics
and
um
uh
my view was I hope that the politics
will catch up with economics so I think
the right answer is that there needs to
be closer economic and political
integration in Europe
and with the events that have happened
since then
both
on the side of what we see in Russia and
to some extent in China and what you see
in the United States with Trump I think
this imperative for Europe to become
more
uh politically United
uh becomes even stronger so to me that
is the answer to the problems that I see
in the Euro but since you made that
advice uh we had brexit so something
went wrong
uh yeah and I think they regret it
and I think they wouldn't do it again
um but you know history has a way of
going in a particular direction
let's move back to the U.S
November 8th what will you be doing
well yeah obviously everybody will be
watching these elections uh
uh I'm hopeful
um and I'm particularly hopeful with the
Senate
uh for a very bad reason
that uh the uh Republicans uh have
overreached
and
um it's a real example of ideology
uh trumping reason
and strategy so
um when the Republican Supreme Court
using really bad law and bad reason bad
logic
decided to reverse Roe versus Wade
what that did is energized large
fractions of the population
now the Supreme Court had made a lot of
other bad decisions too and I could go
through them and that would be America
getting into the weeks of American
politics you know about judgments about
administrative law environmental law
um you know every decision they make is
uh
so contrary to to what I think is reason
um
and exactly I I think extraordinarily
divisive effect uh on America uh not
only uh because of the nature of the you
know of the decisions themselves but Roe
versus Wade for instance has made uh
people who are more Progressive in
America
feel even more that this constitution
that was written
240 years ago written by a group of rich
White
slave owning men
of what legitimacy does that have in the
21st century
and
before this
Supreme Court we had a process where
people were trying to say yes we know
that let's keep let's forget that
origins of that Constitution and we'll
adapt this piece of paper to the times
as they change and that makes sense but
this new these ideologues on the right
are saying oh these were great wise
men who uh got an oracle from heaven
and we now have to interpret that Oracle
and uh we can't just we interpret
as if we were living in 1789. I mean can
you believe that talking about old white
men with power
20th of November it's a big day Biden is
turning 80.
so here's a old white guy
I don't think he's that old let me take
that no no I I think I I don't I'll
dispute that but then
maybe not but are you are you invited to
his birthday what are you invited to his
birthday
okay then we have the the old
influential white guy called Bernie
Sanders he turned 81 last week
how is the Democratic establishment
doing
um
yeah actually there are a lot of good
younger
men and women
uh on the Democratic party
most of these do not get the attention
of go internationally are we talking
about Hillary Clinton or are we talking
about about the governors of Michigan as
a as one example
um and then there are male governors in
in in Illinois and and California that
are very good and dynamic so I think you
know there and and you have to remember
um I mean I I think uh people in Denmark
will appreciate uh you know you have
about six million people a governor of
California
is uh the fifth largest economy in the
world and uh I don't know the exact
number but is probably 30 40 million
people so I mean the experience of being
a governor in a state like California or
even Michigan or Illinois
is a real experience so uh the these are
people who who are uh experienced
political leaders who are very who I
think are very talented and so I think
there is a lot there's a lot more
um there's a lot more talent in the
Democratic party than you're seeing at
the top okay so you're at Optimus I'm an
optimist uh 55 of the Americans they
disapprove of Biden
what about you have you been satisfied
with the president so far
yes yeah actually uh I think he's
managed an extraordinarily
difficult situation
um you know he he began
with a pandemic
ravaging the country
and uh with a uh former president who
thought the way to uh solve the problem
of of uh 19 was to drink chlorine
because it was uh it would kill the
germs it would also kill you but that
was a minor detail
um so uh you you
inherited this where this country that
was both very divided and where uh
ravaged by this disease no uh he came
into office trying you know with with uh
an agenda of trying to calm the country
down
um and at the same time addressed both
the uh disease and the economic Fallout
he put forward a really successful
vaccination program
and uh
uh a economic program
that made the economic downturn in the
United States much less than
anywhere else in the world that have
been incomparable remember we had more
than a million people die from covert
19. so that was really managed well and
at the same time he used those funds to
begin to address some of the social
problems childhood poverty in the United
States which is really unacceptably high
was reduced in one year by 40 percent
so you know that was a a real
achievement
uh he did not succeed in getting the
disease down as quickly as possible that
was because of the irrationality that he
had to deal with what I don't know
anybody could have dealt with the the
anti-vaxxers
and people who refused to wear masks uh
you know the whole
uh reaction against science
was something that was very difficult I
think impossible I don't know if anybody
could have dealt with that
then we had the further political
problem
that he didn't really control the Senate
there's one or two people who were
probably best described as closet
Republicans
um who made it very difficult to get
anything through but he finally got a
large number of bills through you got
the largest climate change bill it also
did a lot for health care costs
uh he got this uh bill on Industrial
policy through I mean very first time
we've ever had anything like that to try
to steer our economy he got a gun
control Bill through uh a veterans Bill
through so you have it it was uh in that
package a lot of achievements so all in
all you're satisfied with the president
and now I have a really really tough
question and it's yes or no
should you run for re-election
um I think yes or no no
um I think if Trump runs it will be very
tempting for him to run
but I think if a younger Republican runs
I think uh almost surely
it will be a younger Democrat that will
run two years from now Biden he will be
82 and which brings me to the subject of
extra young he's still young you have to
remember with with modern medicine
82 was really 62.
I think I think we we know that we know
that yeah
Boomers versus Sumas like the like
there's so many tensions in our
societies and in our economy and there
seems to me that there's a generational
Gap like
like people how many people is under 30
years old here in the audience
I'm so sorry for you guys
are you sorry for them as well
uh it is an important dimension of
inequality in our society you know I've
written a lot about inequality but
inequalities across Generations is an
important topic that has not gotten the
attention that it deserves and I think
uh though you might say the worst the
two worst aspects of this inequality
are climate change that we're giving
them a world that's burning and uh
uh I'll be gone before it fully Burns
but I think it's a real serious problem
that we need to address but the second
uh more mundane issue uh for a very
evident in the United States in many
countries in Europe is young people
can't afford housing
um and uh part of the reason for that is
the low interest rates that have been
maintained the excessively low you know
I complained before about excessively
High interest rates but I also think
that excessively low interest rates can
be a problem since 2008 since the global
financial crisis interest rates have
been close to zero and we have interest
rates that are that low but obviously
inflates asset prices
and uh the owners of those assets were
older people by and large and they
become
if you were wealthy enough in the
beginning you got even wealthier and
that is part of the reason why there's
such high wealth inequality today but
that is a barrier to younger people
getting a house
is it easy to fix
well
I think uh
it's not easy to fix but I think
when asked to recognize that there is
this intergenerational
Equity problem and the result of that is
I think you need to do
subsidies for people who are younger
people buying a house and capital gains
taxes on the capital gains that people
have gotten on their old houses uh it
wasn't anything they did it was monetary
policy that was really the driving force
behind these large Capital gangs and I
think that creates these inequities a
little bit analogous to the inequities
we were talking about before and when
you have these inequities you you
ought to tax the windfall gains and help
those who are being hurt is this
generational Gap is that more important
than the concept of classes
um
I think it
is a first order of importings uh there
is still you know uh as a there's still
large differences between the poor and
the rich
um
Denmark at least a lot of the statistics
I've seen is one of the countries where
there's more social Mobility than others
the United States you know talks about
the American dream but when you look at
the data uh the American dream is a myth
uh that yes there are few people who
make it from the bottom to the top and
that's why newspapers write about them
they're so unusual that it's a it's a
good story
but the what a social scientist talks
about
you know a dream or you know an
opportunity what we mean is what is the
probability
and the probability of somebody at the
bottom making it to the top is very low
in the United States actually lower than
in almost any of the other Advanced
countries
and in Denmark
is higher than an uh our Scandinavia
more generally it's higher and I think
that's one of the attributes that you
should be uh
make sure that you could do everything
to keep
talking about success
which is very interesting if I say the
name Elon Musk what do you say
well I think it's a mixed picture uh you
know I think he's done a a a very
impressive job
of uh succeeding and creating an
electric car
earlier than other people I mean now
everybody's into it but that was an
important innovation uh and he did it
with determination
on the other hand uh
many of his other
uh
activities statements you know we don't
need to send more people
out in outer space you know wasting all
that money you know when we have so many
problems here on Earth that seems a
little bit incongruous
and uh I'm very concerned when he at
first tried to get Twitter and now he
doesn't want to get Twitter but to have
a major
uh
lead media a way people communicate
controlled by
somebody whose views are so peculiar
and you know who who says who doesn't
believe in Social harms I mean you have
a regulatory framework here or you're
about to get a regulatory framework here
that maybe able to mediate to restrict
some of those social harms from social
media
but the United States we have no really
good mechanism and I worry a lot about
having somebody like musk controlling uh
a major way that ideas get disseminated
and he's also like I think he's the
richest person in the world and that's
something that really changed also the
conversation about our economy that we
have these super rich people and there
is this income gap the quality
inequologists growing and going
these super rich people should we be
grateful because like they contribute
with their entrepreneurship you you say
that Elon Musk like he made a this
electric car Tesla and like uh Jeff
Bezos made Amazon and so on like it has
been like in Mark Zuckerberg and and the
Google process like they really made
some great inventions like so
some of these are you know you have to
under uh ask
um they made important Innovations
um they were built on Muslim
on basic research that was funded by the
public they would not have existed
without the internet
and the internet was funded publicly the
creation of the internet was done
largely by the U.S government but some
other governments funded publicly you
couldn't have it without a browser
financed publicly so their success is
based on publicly funded research
secondly somebody like the Zuckerberg
uh
uh
made an innovation that was not that
much different from alternative
uh uh platforms
his was successful the others not but
and that was we call those Network
externalities when lots of people join
on one platform and but that was almost
an accident if you said they had gone to
the other one with the world would have
been much different no and a lot of his
money comes from what I think socially
destructive Behavior getting engagement
in the way of getting engagement is
getting enragement
and so I think they played a very
important role in the polarization of
our society and we know they played a
role in some of the worst things that
have happened like the massacre the
rohingyas
um in Miramar so uh you know some of
their success is built on really
socially harmful uh activity but
whatever you think about that the fact
of the matter is they would have
engaged in that entrepreneurial activity
if we tax them
a lot more if we tax them at 90 percent
they still would have done that you know
can you repeat rather than having did
you say 300 did you say 90 yeah I said
90 okay yeah wow if forever been having
300 billion they had only 30 billion
that's enough to live
um you know and
[Applause]
so Professor six is just to sum up like
we shouldn't worry too much about
inflation we should spend more money and
tax a rich more right yeah yeah wow I'm
starting to getting nervous is that
because I have just if you have 300
billion maybe are you worried about
losing 207
I'm I'm worried about growth in our
society
the point I made is that these guys uh
most of my guys
would have done the same entrepreneurial
activity
and their growth was bounded on
public investment
and we can't have public investment
without
public resources
and if we took that money and recycled
it
in more basic research
more better infrastructure
spending that creates more social
solidarity rather than the kind of
polarization that we have in the United
States we would be a more productive
Society
when we cut the taxes when Trump costs
cut the taxes
in 2017 on the very rich and on the
corporations
the promise was cutting the taxes would
lead to more investment
it didn't didn't mean to anymore what it
did lead to was more share BuyBacks
more dividends more money
uh in the pockets of some of the very
richest but a public sector that was
starved so that we were not able to
respond as effectively as we could have
took over 19.
do you know this joke
two dignitaries are watching a military
parade at the very end after all the
tanks and missiles are and marching men
comes a wagon with a few shabby
political civilians inside
who are the first who are they the first
man asked the second oh the second man
replies those are economists you
wouldn't believe the damage they can
cause
[Laughter]
and and the reason I I mentioned this
joke is that like
you've been talking about ideology is
such an important part of the profession
of economics and and that's probably
brainwashed since I'm worried about the
future of economics and our society when
I'm talking to you uh
what is going to happen right now in the
profession of Economics for like the
next 10 years
well first let me say yeah um you know I
sometimes jokingly say that economists
ought to take the Hippocratic Oath you
know uh when you become a doctor uh you
have to take the Hippocratic Oath which
is Do no harm
and uh there was one occasion where uh
the president of a country wanted to
know whether he should sign a free trade
agreement with the United States and I
happen to know that that president had
been a doctor and had signed the
Hippocratic Oath so I asked him uh what
it
your doctor you did sign the Hippocratic
oath and he said yes and I said well
then you can't uh sign the Free Trade
Agreement
because you're committed to doing no
harm so
um
I think this is actually a very
optimistic time for the economics
profession because we've had 40 Years of
what is sometimes called neoliberalism
the idea that markets solve all problems
and
it hasn't
uh that's shouldn't be news
um that uh growth has been slower than
it was before the era of neoliberalism
most of their growth has benefits of
that growth had gone to the very top
um there's been a lot more instability
we haven't we faced an inequality crisis
a climate crisis
and finally within the economics
profession
not universally but increasingly
especially among young people there's a
an awareness that those set of doctrines
have failed
and there's a search for a new new
thinking about
how do we to go back to the first
question you know how do we organize
this up
to make sure that the there is an
allocation or resources that is
efficient
that promotes growth but is also just
unfair
and that is a question you know about
something that's just unfair and that
addresses issues across Generations like
climate change
that was totally outside the domain of
standard economics for 40 years
sometimes Pikachu
did you read all his books from from the
first page to the last I have to admit
no
[Laughter]
if I had I think uh
I would have been underwater
but but you know his occupants right
what you know his arguments like I know
his argument I know him very well yeah
and is he he's part of a new generation
of economic thinkers that will change
the profession from the inside yeah I
mean he's very very concerned about
inequality
uh he's provided an enormous data set
that allows us to study inequality
across time across countries over time
that is really
enlightened us about the magnitude uh of
that inequality and this most recent
book
I mean I think he's made a a real effort
to show how looking at these issues
from a broader perspective bringing in
history and politics is going to be the
way you have to approach
these questions
he's become insanely popular why is that
you think
well I think people are really concerned
about these issues which were not in uh
why do we discuss within economics I
mean when even today I mean say
standard courses in economics do not
even mention inequality or do not
discuss inequality
I teach a required
grad your PhD course in economics but
it's a course that's required because
the standard courses
have excluded
most of the things that are interesting
I think so in our course we talk about
inequality we talk about innovation
we talk about behavioral economics but
so much of of of what is of Interest
today
is
not included in the standard framework
so I think I think uh what he's talked
about resonates with the problems where
of global society today I know that in
the audience we have many Danish
Business Leaders should they be
concerned about the inequality
uh yes
um and you you can say that they should
be concerned for several reasons I mean
the most fundamental you might say is
moral
that uh
[Music]
you know what is a just society and
just because you're a business leader
you're still part of society and so
everybody should be thinking about these
questions
but secondly
I think a dividing Society doesn't
function well
and you know
what I say to people in Europe in places
like uh
uh Denmark look at the United States is
that if that's what you want
don't think about equality
if you want a very dividing society and
you see what that does to tear apart the
fabric the inability to make public
Investments the inability you know
to to resolve common issues that comes
in part because we haven't excessively
divided Society
and finally
uh I think uh it's good business uh I
think
workers who are not paid decent wages
are not likely to be as productive so so
the business of business is still
business
uh
it's part of what they have to do and
and I think
um but all these come together I mean I
you know there was a a dinner at uh
Davos uh that I go to every every year
and and
um uh these are you know some very
important uh leading business
uh and a couple years ago what are the
Striking conversations was that one of
the Business Leaders said he hadn't
realized
that a majority of his workers were not
getting a living wage
and in the United States you have the
minimum wage is seven uh dollars and a
quarter that you know roughly fifteen
thousand dollars a year
and uh you can't quite pay rent
for that in New York City
and there are a lot of firms paying that
minimum wage
and what he did after he I mean you you
I was surprised that he didn't realize
that but some of our previous meetings
had induced him to go back and look at
what his
salaries what he was paying and he
raised all of his workers salaries to
what he viewed as a livable wage well
above the minimum wage
he felt better about it but I think he
also felt it was better for the company
Better Business sure better business
time is running so fast and we have some
people in the streaming we have to say
goodbye to them now five minutes
missions to have you around somewhere in
the world and now we opened the floor
for questions so